[Music]
brazil's military
is dealing with uh quite a bit of
controversy because the um is all the
soldiers got fat asses now
too sexy standard issue butt lift too
sexy so their military has been buying a
lot of viagra
what glot really like 35 000 viagra
pills can you buy that on base maybe
it's for training it's not for training
oh it's not okay the military's buying
not the not the uh like the the
department's buying not the individual
brazilian military is it their marines
or navy or army this is military oh so
it's on paper as like an expense yep
like you're buying like 40 torpedoes and
then also 35 thousand dollars worth
cialis and viagra yeah that's right
so is that bad uh
the generic version of viagra is what
they're buying by the way in 25 saving
money for the government right 25
milligrams 50 milligram doses okay um
since 2020. so like that's quite a lot
of viagra and everyone's like what the
[ __ ] is going on well it's also known
um to help
when people have hypertension so if you
have if you have pulmonary hypertension
yeah um that's what it was used for yeah
for blood pressure yeah regulator so
they're like wait wait it's not what you
think it's for hypertension it's a cheap
alternative for hypertension but
they're giving all of their servicemen
serious [ __ ] boners
obviously right they're treating the
hypertension they didn't know they're
gonna be dealing with this so they're
just like man my hypertension is gone
but dude i got hypertension down here
bro you're right it's tension it's of
tension lots of hypertension what do you
do if you're dealing with a lot of
tension down there
you need attention down you need to
[ __ ] get it sucked off or something
so guess what they had to do
all day
no i wish they had to go to a bravo it's
just about how they they have
hypertension
the rest is up to us
or they sucked each other off for us but
we can only dream we have to fill in the
blanks yeah i think that's part of
training i think it's good for training
i mean the thai military would have
probably done it that way that's what
they did right they got the [ __ ] come
from the brazilian military
hey trade relations man wow you got to
keep them up have any of you guys taken
viagra nope no i haven't we should have
[ __ ] brought back nigel i hear some
people that like to party uh they don't
need it but they'll take half to like go
the extra mile i'm curious i heard that
i would do it i would do it in a second
if we all did it together i would do it
only we did together
with the boys
and we're all just raging [ __ ] boners
we're sweating and we're together that's
it together
only if we're in a sauna we're all doing
it together all of us like yo steve
walks out he's like yeah
that's not true he knocks over his
[ __ ] laptop if i'm driving a go-kart
i don't know if it was one of our
friends but someone told me that they
took it
without having erectile dysfunction and
then it [ __ ] them up afterwards and
that's what scared me i was like above
nine hours like that kind of [ __ ] like
it was a long time yeah isn't that a
really like harsh thing you have to do
to fix that
i heard it's like a shot or something
yeah you want to get it like drained or
something yeah we did an article where
this guy had to [ __ ] um get it
surgically like helped and [ __ ] like
they had to cut his dick so blood would
actually they had to bleed it dude dude
apparently uncle roger's taking those
things like they're [ __ ] jelly beans
i don't have an uncle orgies and [ __ ]
damn right based off of what he said too
can't you just bust a nut and then
and it go down that's what he says he
says that's never going up against
anything that goes wrong apparently
sometimes something doesn't go down
uncle roger said on the record
because it wasn't off the record i was
there
he said i took the viagra you come you
never come again in your life you never
get hard again that's what he said
that's what he said that's why i'm
scared to take it if i don't have dick
problems scares me uncle roger can't get
hard anymore yeah that is pretty scary
that's why people take half of it half
of them well they take it with alcohol
too a lot of people
yeah
whoa i don't know how i used to do so
many drugs in a night and like now i
hear these things and i'm like wow that
sounds excessive doesn't it what was
your stack back in the day like it was a
normal night so there used to be this
thing called suicide because you
remember back in the day
when we saw all the sodas yeah this is
all the stories all the soda it came
from that because like when you're a kid
you're like you ready to suicide and
there was what's that and you think it's
like bad right because it's like you go
to the soda machine and you're like i'm
gonna put in some coke and then i'm
gonna put some orange [ __ ] drinks
you're like what you could do that [ __ ]
i did like that right he's crazy
those same [ __ ] dumbass kids came up
with the idea of you know what we'll do
i'm a [ __ ] take a hit a weed right
here and i'ma [ __ ] take a pill right
here i'll [ __ ] do a little bit of
hitta cake and i'm going dude dude gotta
play with the glow stick man and i think
those are the kind of kids
over the edge yeah yeah that's right do
i hit a glow stick dude crack it open so
none of them would die i don't know but
but they called it suicide at times
they'll be so anti-suicide for them to
die i remember one day um we were on
some pills we did eat this was like when
i was like 14 or 15. how many of them
how many substances did you do so i did
e we were coming down on e
so we did acid
and then we went to an after party and
then some guy had some weed
and then the weed they laughed because
they said someone put prozac in it whoa
what does prozac do i think it's like an
antidepressant but it was the weirdest
[ __ ] trip i've ever had but it was
probably because of the combination of
the acid in the weed and it just so
happens that someone had more acid so we
fried some more
so we didn't you fried the ass no no
acid is called frying oh it's called
double double dose noob
anthony's never done acid before you
guys oh my god yeah depression panic
attacks obsessive compulsive disorder
and also bulimia whoa whoa
prozac i don't know probably makes you
feel really but i think it was really
the combination between the weed and the
acid that was the most craziest trip
what did you see yeah what did what
happened where did you go
i was just like really in my head and
then i was just thinking in deep thought
chasing different thoughts talking to
friends like trying to calm down like
trying to get into the sober state
but the scariest thing was watching my
friends in repeat like i had my one
buddy um
he had a hula hoop and he kept going
like that and then he would the hula
hoop would go up and he would catch it
you know how you yeah yeah yeah slide it
like that and he kept going
and then that music video
uh you know that song i see you baby
shaking that ass you know yeah that was
playing and until he started repeating
that and then other people started
repeating that everyone kept saying it
over and over and over and i was like
shut the [ __ ] up
and then they're looking at me like i'm
being mean and they're like oh you're
giving us a bad trip man and i'm all
like [ __ ] and then i had to go to a
different room and i spent the rest of
the time just talking on aim
like just just save me were you telling
people shut the [ __ ] up
did you have a bad trip yeah i mean
every it was it was kind of weird you
know like i just remember going in and
out of it and then like feeling like i'm
doing the same thing like like that over
and over you got caught in the loop yeah
so it felt like a loop yeah and then
people were pacing back and forth around
me and i'm like i think everyone else
was or maybe they were and then some
people were talking and laughing and
joking and then so i just went on my
friend's computer and i was just
chatting with all my friends trying to
sober up and [ __ ] and then like i was
talking to sober people and they were
grounding me because i was i know
they're sober so i'm like i know you're
talking like so like just [ __ ] keep
chatting with me yeah i've seen friends
get caught in the loop like that too and
it's like the hardest thing it's like an
inception where you don't know if this
is real or not and you need that [ __ ]
spinny spin to to tell you like yeah but
we don't know what happened what is the
result of that like what do you think
that's mostly from is it just from the
acid i don't know which drug i think
prompt that [ __ ] behavior
i think definitely it's for sure the
drug but then like it also has to do
with like you and like your energy and
your intention in that moment your
attitude but this was like six in the
morning too oh [ __ ] i couldn't go to
sleep
we're out of this person's house and
then my friend decides to let's go so
i'm like all right so we get in the car
and his ass is still [ __ ] up so we're
looping around this whole neighborhood
and we're getting paranoid so i'm like
dude
how come we're not going home we're just
we've been passing the house three four
times and then he's like i'm too tired i
can't think anymore so we finally get
out we finally get out right and then
like you know when you're like seeing
like people walk their dogs and jogging
in the morning and just like they
[ __ ] nowhere high they're gonna call
the cops we gotta go home and [ __ ] right
get all paranoid get paranoid and then
we went to a [ __ ] ralph's parking lot
and the next thing i know
is i'm being woken up by a security
guard hitting the [ __ ] window like
you guys got to get out of here
and then like i don't even remember
like sleeping i just remember we were
pulling up teleported huh and then we're
at the parking lot and boom i'm knocked
out i'm waking up and the security
guard's knocking on the thing and i'm
just like oh [ __ ] and then we go home
it's like moon night there's just like
blood all over yeah
yeah yeah when it was like what just
probably middle of the day because it
was already 6 a.m right they probably
like
knocked on your door like this was
probably like 10 at that time
there's customers already yeah it was
like 10 or 11. don't want your kids to
do drugs just show them this [ __ ]
video show them joe's story all right
that that sounds so annoying i don't
want it i dude my friend spent half the
night trying to look at his eyes
dude i was like he was just cross side
trying to get him focused
i was laughing for an hour straight so
he's in the loop no no he was talking to
us and in the middle of the conversation
he goes
like that right and we're like yo yo yo
yo you okay and he's like
oh
i was trying to see my eyes
dude people on drugs are so [ __ ]
annoying we're like yeah
that's crazy like if you don't get it it
looks like what and we were dying cuz
like i couldn't process what he was
saying but he was looking at the back of
his eye trying to look at his eyeball
well i figured yeah he's like
oh like he was coming and [ __ ] we're
like whoa whoa whoa i thought we were
going to collapse backwards because he
was [ __ ] looking back so hard and
he's like oh
i was trying to see my own eyes and then
you walked away and i was like what the
[ __ ] he never saw his eyes again no nick
he kept going like this and [ __ ] cause i
think he was trying to look at his the
back of his head and something i went to
me and nikki were at this [ __ ] you
know how you go to like some douchey la
thing and then they're like hey dude
this is going to be a psychedelic
experience and like okay cool and then
you so i i wasn't on anything i think
that's what you're supposed to do so i
just go into this [ __ ] tent and it's
like i'm supposed to be psychedelic
you're not on anything i don't know dude
i was just some [ __ ] ellie dude it's
probably the [ __ ] crystals and the
[ __ ] things that they do around you
and you're like oh
or the wisdom
well that and like you know how you go
to these places it's like we're artsy
and it's like you know now you have an
art experience you're like whatever
whatever i already hate all this why not
just immerse myself in the hatred of all
this [ __ ] so that i go in this tent and
they have you laid out on a bean bag and
they're everyone and you have to wait
like forever to get in there of course
i'm like welcome to your experience and
like god damn it doesn't suck right you
would love that and then i go in there
and it's like [ __ ] screen savers
everywhere and it's like you can talk
you can tell the artist thought this was
like the deepest most molecular thing
that ever happened and like you could
tell you just he like smokes weed or
drops out and he's like he's like dude
this [ __ ] takes you to a [ __ ]
different plane like you're allowed to
experience like a different endeavor
than perhaps the most humanity can
like you just see like if we got five
monitor screen savers in some [ __ ]
beanbag chairs honestly the bouncing
ball that doesn't hit the corner is like
deeper than the [ __ ] like you you see a
[ __ ] moth like turn into a butterfly
like turn into a [ __ ] caterpillar
it's like oh it shouldn't go in that
order and he's like exactly
okay
yeah and then you're in space but then
it's like space just all looks the same
copy paste it all across the thing
because you think they couldn't afford
to do much more
and it just decided to see the pattern
repeat yeah
i was so annoyed and like looking at my
[ __ ] phone the whole time and just
being like man me and nikki both
the best thing about nikki is like we
both look at life the same way and so
we're both just now like this guy i
thought he's so [ __ ] good
that's the best but when you look into
your left and right and people that were
on [ __ ] were like oh yeah this is it
yeah
oh yeah but that's how annoying it is to
be the sober one while everyone's
[ __ ] like tanked around you or like
at least were they what were they on
ecstasy
i don't know now but now that i was in
there i was like man everyone's [ __ ]
based off this description it's
definitely an acid type of place to be
mushrooms or acid uh well for example
like shrooms i'm like i need to go to
nature right whereas acid
to see
like the idea of like you know butterfly
to cocoon or whatever i feel like that
stuff's much more acid triggering that's
true acid is like the back posters of
hot topic sure but glowy posters the
black light but acid is also looking at
those posters and realizing that they're
not like visual they're actually like a
language if you're like on it you
wouldn't see it like a visual poster you
would understand it as if it was
speaking so you sound like the artist
and i hate you
being a 14 year old boy on acid you
think you're einstein
[Music]
you